what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on super-pumped
to be talking about Google
whistleblowing and AI censorship we have
a Zak 4 he's joining us on the show
hi Zak hey thanks Alan good to be on the
show thanks so much for coming on really
appreciate all your great work that
you've been doing thank you thank you
thank you and it's so cool that we even
had the chance to meet several years ago
and we were doing our science comedy
show and that we've been in touch for a
while and it's great seeing what you've
been doing in our world and I'm so
pumped to unpack it with you for those
that don't know Zak's bio he was a
senior software engineer at YouTube
Google until he discovered their AI
censorship weapons now he's a
whistleblower fighting against
censorship of you and you can find his
Twitter profile in the bio below Zak
we've got to start things off on this
point you know we find ourselves
embedded in this reality and we're all
trying to figure out what we're doing
here why were even here in the first
place how we can maximize prosperity and
one of the things that's so close to our
hearts is our ability to say what's on
our mind and to be able to query
the knowledge base of civilization and
not have those things be biased with
some hidden agenda or for people to not
be able to have a voice but it's also
nuanced in a respect because you don't
want to see murders happening on the
internet and other stuff like that so
how do you see all of that kind of
currently being mixed together and what
we can do well I think that if in order
to have a marketplace of free Commerce
you have to have a marketplace of free
ideas and when I joined Google in 2008
that's what Google stood for was you
know this we're gonna have like a new
form of freedom that's going to be
unlocked with technology
and you know come join us we're gonna
change the world we're going to disrupt
it's gonna be a much better world and
that's what I signed up for and that's
what I was helped doing for the eight
and a half years that I was working at
the company but then something changed
and they decided that they were going to
betray all their corporate values that
they announced during their IPO which is
you know don't be evil
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful and they decide to just toss that
all away in order to satisfy their
political agenda and I'm realizing now
that that they're doing it as they have
been able to achieve a monopoly it's a
big problem because you know being big
is not really a problem being bad is not
really a problem but being big and being
bad that's a problem and that's the the
place we find ourselves today and of
monopoly is the other thing is when
there's no one else that you go to to
when you want to query the world's
information that's been organized and
that you have these main principles this
is such a nuanced point it's so
difficult to get to some of the most
important roots of this because we use
so many of the incredible technologies
that are being brought forth by Google
we all use the maps feature we a lot of
us use the mail feature a lot of us use
Android technology the web browser a lot
of us again query the the the knowledge
base of society but the question is
what's happening when we do that what's
going on in the background when we do
that how can we build a trusting
relationship between an organization
that claims to organize the world's
knowledge and the way that I query it in
my relationship with that well it's
really easy you know you just let the
algorithm
figure it out right like the way that
Google was able to rise up as the number
one search company is that they figured
out that the importance of a website was
determined by how many things were able
to link back to it so for example you
know we and we already have this
intuitively for scholarly papers right
how do you know whether a paper is a
really high quality piece of science
well a good signal for that is how many
people are citing it so if I see a paper
and it's got like you know 200 other
papers that you know cited as a basis of
its research for their research then I
think to myself okay well this is a
Thorat ativ piece this is obviously very
useful for the progression of science
you know if I see a paper that has zero
like citation links to it then I know
that nobody gives a crap about it hasn't
really done a lot to further science
because no one's using it as a
foundation to you know advance science
well Google took you know essentially
the way that science works and then
applied it to the Internet and said
let's figure out you know how important
something is based upon how many people
link to it and you know what that was a
winning formula that worked really well
and Google became a really big company
because of all their searching that
people were able to do and find him the
information that they were looking for
and and now that they're applying the
censorship it looks like you know
they're trying to make things more
complex they're adding a lot of stuff to
their engine in order to bias these
these results let me give you an example
of what that looks like let's do it so
Google has an army of human rancors that
go through and figure out the
authoritative nosov a website they
called the each score stands for
expertise authoritative Ness and
trustworthiness of
website Wow every single website has an
each score I don't know if every single
website has a neat score but but angular
ones but the but I think the results
that appear on the front page have a
neat score so what they do is you know
they go and they say well you know is
this site authoritative well what
they've what they've done with how they
rank a authoritative missus of a website
is that they say what does Wikipedia
have to say about this website okay you
know if Wikipedia says oh this website
like has all these like accolades and
has all these glowing things that people
have said they've won all these awards
then Google's gonna be like their radar
working for Google is going to manually
add a high score for that website now if
a website has a bunch of slander
attached to it oh this person is a
conspiracy theorist or whatever well
then that websites gonna get like a
really low score so the literally using
the opinion of what wikipedia has to say
about something in order to bias the
results and the question is will you
know how how authentic is is Wikipedia
how much does it accurately reflect the
consensus of the internet and one of the
things that a lot of people have noted
including myself is that Wikipedia is
being vandalized they're closing the
gates so that people that can't get
access to edit a Wikipedia article even
if they're if the Wikipedia article is
about themselves they can't even like
correct the record and for some reason
you've got all these social justice
warriors that seem to have a predominant
amount of access to Wikipedia and
they're they're they're getting rid of
everyone that has like a conservative
bent and as a result like the entire
Internet's being rescued based upon you
know what Wikipedia is doing so they've
they've gone from an algorithmic company
to a let's like rate everything
according to what wikipedia says about
it which means that Wikipedia is now a
real
highly politicised a ranking system for
the entire internet and you know who
asked for this right like nobody asked
for this everyone loved the Google
algorithm they thought it was really
good we were able to find the
information now as a lot of people noted
you can't find a lot of the things when
you do a search anymore and the reason
why you can't do these things when
you're doing a search anymore is because
Google is deciding that it's each score
it's expertise authoritative Ness and
trustworthiness is low so it's it's like
pushing it to like you know the second
or the third of the you know 15th page
on the search engine and so it
disappears due to specific keywords
being used like if someone labels you a
conspiracy theorist or if someone is
trying to make you seem like what your
your trustworthiness is low then you get
you get down ranked to the point where
your each score shows up on you only
show up on the second page which what is
it like such a small small percentage of
people go to the second page right
everyone's trying to go for the first
five links right that's that's the top
spot so so yeah then it so this is such
a big challenge that even comes up in
the first place is this idea that okay
can we over it's been just 20 years
really of trying to aggregate the
world's information and try and put it
somewhere that's that's you can query it
this is a very tough thing to do but
then how do you actually make it so that
it's that it does the does the most
optimal job possible and it brings the
most good to the world and it doesn't
allow evil to happen well I think that
the system that they had before was
working really well to do that there was
really no complaints super like Wow
Google is amazing and now it's like wow
I'm getting better results off the
alternative search engines and you know
to find information so what you know and
this is like DuckDuckGo is one of them
yeah dr. Joe start pile no start page
dogpile being in Yahoo are actually now
better in a lot of ways then Google is
interesting
I want to ask then this is this is one
way that we are also query
of there's all the other social
platforms that we use to query
information there's there's the there's
there's different combinatorics that are
happening across the world you have the
United States which has a different
relationship between its government and
its corporations than does China for
example when you have their government
and the way they interplay with Baidu
which is like their main search engine
so okay well what would it look like you
know what does that you know what are
all these different like permutations
that are kind of rising in different
countries and different browsers and the
way that people are using to try and
query knowledge is it possible that then
there is a most optimal solution that's
kind of gonna grow out of this it's
obviously really important to figure
this out because when you have people
that are trying to use the internet to
communicate things out into the world
and then if the decision is made by any
of these different megaphones to decide
to eliminate your ability to say
something it can take away from the
possibility and then you throw money and
the involvement of power and those
dynamics into the equation this is very
important to get right yeah yeah I mean
China has you know the state is more
powerful than the corporation's and as a
result they have censorship in
everything I mean they've got the Great
Wall of China the Great Firewall China
yeah and as a result you can't keep
information into the country you know if
you want to look at a YouTube video in
China just not gonna work I mean I use a
VPN if to use a VPN and they've been
cracking down the BP ends and it's
getting harder and harder and harder in
order to get through that firewall it's
really becoming like an impenetrable
barrier and so
you know that's not gonna work very well
I mean it it's weird in a Chinese style
system you can still find good
information as long as it has nothing to
do with politics right like if you want
to learn how injection molding works
they're not gonna censor that
information because it's not politically
sensitive but if you want to have the
freedom of of ideas you're not going to
be able to find the truth and the thing
is is that everyone in China knows that
that's the way that it's going it's kind
of like Russia and the Soviet Union
everyone knew that the government was
lying and that's sort of the way it is
in China right now this is again this is
how does this how do we do this
optimally you don't want to see a
slip-up by one of these platforms where
all of a sudden I'm seeing a
recommendation of a beheading video on
my feed so there there's free speech is
crucial but also don't up like how did
they prevent the uploading of rape or
prevent the uploading of violence or or
underage pornography and various porn so
what do you think about about that yeah
so the thing is is that there's a lot of
people right now that are saying oh we
need like a blockchain solution so that
we can like not get stuff taken down I'm
like yeah as soon as you have that
someone's gonna open up CP is gonna like
upload some underage porn and then the
whole society is going to be like we
have to reconfigure ourselves so we can
like get rid of it so the whole thing
that you can have like an immutable
database that once you post something it
stays there no one could take it down
yeah that's just not going to happen you
need to have a system which you can
remove content that is obscene and
offensive you know and I don't mean like
oh like I'm trigger defensive I mean
like no no this is like really offensive
you know not an expression of idea just
like you know underage pornography like
how do you get rid of that let's just
use that as an example yeah I believe
that you should be able to have a
community moderation tool so enough
people report something as you know I
find this obscene and then it gets
flagged for review and then
one says yeah this is definitely not
cool and then they remove it right like
I don't think that that you know I mean
you can even be that is that the people
say no this is obscene and then like a
machine learning algorithm can go
through and look at that and say yep
this looks like you know pornography so
sorry gets you know eliminated and then
the person that uploaded it gets a
chance to appeal and then if they appeal
then there's like a human judge that
comes in and says you know did that did
the algorithm did the machine learning
algorithm make the right choice I think
that's the best way you have to drive it
to democracy the problem with these tech
companies is that they're so obsessed
with control you want to centralize
everything right YouTube is like oh we
want to be the arbitrators of what's
socially acceptable or not and really
what should happen is that should be
decentralized like push the control of
reporting the video is obscene to the
edges as far as possible you know you're
still gonna have the problem of like you
know mobs coming on and saying oh we
don't like this content because it
actually doesn't say something that we
like you know and and then you you know
you have to have a fail-safe for that
you need to be able to prevent political
speech from being wrongly removed
because you know of mob attacks right
and there's a solution for all this
you've got to push up to the edge and
decentralize it but have a central
arbitrator at the end of the day you
know making a decision on that and I
think that's scalable I think that
really works but we're really not seeing
that right now we're basically you know
like you sent your lies it out to the
communities let the communities
themselves flag for obscene content like
on various child pornography interesting
and then have that and then the question
is you know can it be flaked fast enough
how many eyeballs you know does he get
to before it gets flew no and the thing
is is that we're gonna have a lot of
like machine learning algorithms that
are like AI is getting really good right
so you know at some point you can have
an AI that like is a specialist and the
sort of things and then it says
classifies and says okay hey wow this
might be you know let's flag it for
human review like it just
they Flags it for him and it doesn't
even go up for a community to review
because they can tell that there's a
problem like something like that in it
and then there's also this strike policy
as well what do you how do you feel
about these account like in terms of the
account and having an account that's off
that is linked and authenticated to an
actual human being and that way yeah so
instead of anonymous that way if if you
are posting content that is obscene or
that is violent and then you get a
couple strikes than your yeah so how do
we do that so this this concept of an
amenity and you know being something
created by human are usually entrained
with each other like that they're kind
of mashed together as one subject and
they're actually like two different
subjects right because you know the one
thing is you want to make sure that you
don't want to have these BOTS going and
generating content and then posting it
because the thing is is that with with a
is getting a lot better
those bot Wars are insane when you look
at those videos and pictures of those
little cellphone farms and how there's
just a ton of different cellphones with
fake accounts following fake accounts
posting yeah the click farms are out of
control right and what they're doing is
that they're mobbing peope like videos
and they're like downloading it or
they're up voting it and you know it
becomes very clear to like what's going
on when you see a video and you look at
the graph of this likes-dislikes and
then you see like 6000 dislikes come
within 30 minutes I've seen that before
right and they'll they'll do that to
like try to like manipulate the
algorithms and tech companies could
solve this but they don't because they
want the manipulation because the
oligarchs that run the world enjoy being
able to manipulate the conversation and
we'll get into this in more depth in a
little bit yes global ruling you know
you can always tell you can always tell
when something's being manipulated
because
I'll give you an example I go to Twitter
and you see someone that has like you
know a million followers okay and then
they post like a tweet and they'll have
like 30 likes okay
I have almost 27,000 followers on
Twitter which isn't that much and it's a
lot more than I used to have but it's
not that much but yet I'll get 200 likes
when I do a posting why because I have
real people that follow me and people
like Rosie O'Donnell choose an example
she doesn't get any engagement why
because her followers are fake and it's
the same thing with all these media
outlets they're they're purchasing users
that will like follow them so that they
they have a higher precision the
algorithms are pushing them up and those
fake account farms that we were talking
about thats when you buy you get those
fake account farms to follow you yeah so
my friend and my friend Patrick Ryan
helped Milo we had Pat Ryan yeah on the
show yeah yeah yeah we had that right
yeah he liked him a lot
yeah he's great yeah so we talked a lot
about the point of creation and what's
actually happening here what how the
manipulations are happening we right
yeah we went really deep into that so as
you may know that pisode is a Gnostic
warfare for those yeah interested yeah
on our Channel yeah he's really into the
Gnostic warfare this whole thing he's
developed would you would you interview
it by the way
maybe like nine ish months ago okay
maybe fry no yeah so he bought 20,000
followers for Milo innopolis and was
able to like push him up and Milo got so
popular that Steve Bannon decided to
back him so you know how much 20,000
followers cost fifty dollars now keep in
mind this was like 2016 I believe so a
lot of people didn't know like this even
existed especially the older people
didn't know but you know I know
personally like this tactic being used
in order to boost like signals and now
that the secret's out of the bag
everyone's doing it but you know none of
the followers are real they're created
you know ephemerally by you know a form
of people or by a bot and then they go
and they follow somebody and then that's
it and then they then then the bots and
then they get too cheap to keep on
paying for all the likes and retweets
so the botnets just sort of just goes
like cold they they kind of like that
don't do it and they just kind of sit
there and they don't do anything and
this is this is the way that a lot of
our online discourse is is manipulated
by Twitter already that's even its
people worse there they've got an active
system of suppression and they've got
people that come in and post in the
comments section and the reason why is
because reddit started to form a very
large rebellious nature against that the
technology arcs because of the way that
they're able to comment is amazing I was
like oh my god right it's amazing like
the the critique all that mainstream
media stories and show that's [ __ ]
well now you go on there and it seems
that all of reddit is now controlled in
the political the world news the news
itself and it's it's it's it's a huge
problem
like all these fake users out there
shills whatever we can't verify their
identity the tech companies don't want
to have something in there that
you know verifies it China has figured
this out because what they do is they
tie it to your phone number mm-hmm so
it's like well look if you're gonna if
you're gonna make a bot then you're
gonna have to pay the cell phone bill to
have that number and that that gets rid
of 99% of the problems because people
want to do it where they're paying a
penny per user fifteen dollars per user
just makes the whole like issue super
expensive they're not gonna do it
interesting what an interesting solution
and that's kind of what we were talking
about where it's a bunch of different
carbonates corks that are happening in
different countries but it's also the
actual software platforms themselves
like we were giving these examples of
different search engines that can be
used or different social platforms that
can be used and then the idea is that
can you then let these forces go and
sort of compete for humans that for
humans to figure out which which of
these forces are the most decentralized
enable the most free speech have the
best policies for taking down content
that's violent or child pornography or
rape etc and then which ones
um do you hold most dearly to their to
that pillar of their ethos which says
that they want to help be a positive
catalyst for conscious evolution on the
planet and I look forward to figuring
out what one is that gonna be and how do
we help participate in that well right
now there's a lot of anger because what
happens is that for these alternative
social media platforms that try to do
that they get banned
okay so gab calm is a really good
example they launched there was this
operation where I think the deep state
went in and started like posting Hitler
stuff and then the media is like oh my
god gap is filled with Hitler stuff so
we got abandoned now so wow so this
these types of operations can just take
down the the incumbency of ruling elite
could have these operate yeah they just
every time you get something that
challenges the elite the the the the
social media networks owned by the
oligarchs they just play the the
Holocaust card of the Hitler card and
and then as a result
gap got taken off of the app store they
had an app for iPhone and they had an
app for Android and now they are both
removed now they're just web-based
another web-based yeah there's no native
app so you have to like log in through a
web app to it in order to use them wow I
mean this is the problem so the thing is
is that the community on gap has a chip
on their shoulder mmm yeah because all
that media came saying that old they let
this happen yeah in a sense that would
be like saying that a Twitter or YouTube
or whatever had some video on it and oh
my gosh all these hit pieces and you
have to you can't you have to remove the
YouTube or Twitter apps from the app
stores that's yeah that's right and
there they're claiming to be platforms
under Section 230 where they say hey we
get like liability from being sued
because we're platforms so you can't
hold us like you know responsible for
the content and then they shredded that
immunity by acting as a publisher
because they start censoring not because
of things were objectionable but because
they were aligned with a political
agenda or not yeah so then maybe a
solution of sorts would be that then if
you wanted to remain completely in a
sense agnostic to the content and you
yourself so there's no political agenda
you're not allowed to have any political
agenda but rather it you act as just a
medium for free speech communication and
then what you do from there is you
create that decentralized
ability to flag content and have the
machine learning algorithms that are
also working on it but again how do you
like how do you have algorithms that are
you know yeah bias towards finding
things that are violent or rape or child
pornography got that but then then this
is always you know how do you have that
fairness and that approach how do you
have how do you prevent a bot farm from
coming on and flagging your piece of
contacts because I may have an agenda
that's different than this is such an
interesting well yeah like I mean the
thing is like I said like you know if
you have a phone number tied to a user
then you can't create a bot farm to come
in I think that's that's the best
solution for that you know and the thing
is is that people are snitches like this
happens all over society you know Soviet
Union is like oh this person is doing
something wrong you know and that's just
like someone's like violating housing
codes like for something that's like
violent or like obscene you're gonna
have people that you know their biggest
joy in the life is hitting that report
button and removing content off the
platform because they know that it's
objectionable so you know there's just
these trigger-happy people that will
just hit the report button whenever they
get a chance to you know see something
that's that's objectionable yeah okay
let's venture into the deep state and
the global ruling elite you know what's
going on I mean it's a big in many ways
it feels like it's a big game of like
risk and monopoly and Sims that we're
all experiencing together and that there
is some sort of powers that are being
channeled through that are purposely in
creation to make it more to rise more to
the challenge that you're put into a
utopia there's no challenge to rise to
but here we have this big challenge of
conscious evolution to rise to but what
are these forces that are channeling
through people and then how is that
being acted upon our world you gave that
example with gap yeah yeah so you know
the oligarchs that rule the world have a
script and that script is based on
control of the people I think like the
etymology of the word government
actually means like mind control or
something like that and the thing is is
that people don't change their behavior
to positive stimuli
I mean drugs food sex like these core
things they will do that but if your
life is really easy like you know rich
kids that have everything that they want
they don't tend to make you know very
voracious entrepreneurs right because
life has been easy so the people that
had a hard life that you know become
like modify their behavior so that they
become like a type-a workaholic people
respond to trauma and the way that the
ruling elites know how to run society is
by traumatizing people so that they
changed their their behavior and so the
only way that you can traumatize someone
is you know either by physical pain
either by emotional pain and for those
two the types you know you can inflict
emotional pain by saying oh we're going
to like we're going to give you some
scarcity like you know you're you're
you're you're a victim and you don't you
know the reason why you don't have what
you want in life is because you've been
victimized by this other class of people
and so if they can pump that into
people's heads you know whether it's
based on your skin color based upon your
sex or your chosen identity if if you
feel oppressed then you will feel
traumatized and if you're traumatized
then you're controllable and so all mine
control is based on trauma it's it's
it's not even like something that's like
conscious it's like the the lizard brain
part of who we are
won't actually modify the behavior
unless we're traumatized in some way and
so all the things that you see like all
the methods of mind control whenever
there's a church being built the first
thing they want to do is they want to be
like okay well you should feel bad about
the things that you do with it with that
with the you know Catholic Church it was
like you know original sin you're in
debt to God and they want to make you
feel like you're in debt like debt isn't
just about money it's like a fundamental
aspect of human behavior so you're in
debt you're sinful you're a bad person
and as a result of that you need to do X
Y & Z in order to redeem yourself
this template has been recycled over and
over and over by these social engineers
right
white privilege you should feel bad
about being white because you've made
everyone else really poor and put them
in poverty because of your prosperity
everyone else is doing bad oh and by the
way every time you drive your car you're
wrecking the planet every single thing
where you're like god I feel so bad
about this oh man
and the only way to like redeem yourself
is do activism oh hey I gotta like raise
awareness and like show every people
like that this thing is bad they need to
like change their behavior kind of the
same way I'm doing right and that
Redemption like sort of quality like
that's the through the through the
redemption process is the way that we're
controlled in order to enact change and
we you know we fight amongst each others
we want to overthrow the government all
these different things that we do
contribute towards moving our society to
one that is controlled by ruling
oligarchy you know now we've got like
this fake democracy that is like that's
in the Western world and throughout a
lot of the different world you know
monarchies tend to be a little bit more
stable but the most stable state that
was ever created was in Egypt and that
form of government is what I call cult
States and the cult state lasted for
5000 years
it's my belief that the ruling oligarchs
of the world are trying to get us back
into a cult state where the leader is
aligned with God and everybody worships
them and if you don't then you get
brutally punished in Egypt if you didn't
you know like the Pharaohs you try to
rebel against them they would shut off
your water and then everyone's dead and
three in three days because it's a
freaking desert right that's the kind of
world that the ruling elite wants to
recreate and the only way that they
could convince us to give up our
democracy and overthrow the Constitution
is they gotta make things really bad
they gotta traumatize us a lot and then
the solution the atonement is
overthrowing the government and putting
the globalists in charge of running
things and then when we find out oh it's
actually like a state of feudalism and
oh by the way it's gonna be that the the
leader is going to be this cult figure
like you know say Obama for example he
was there was he had like a cult
following oh we can like the media
worshipped him right this is the kind of
template that they're going for and
that's the way that the oligarchs want
to run society and it's up to us as
individuals to say no no no you you
oligarchs are the source of the problems
right you create the wars you create the
shortages and the thing is is that what
we have to realize is that the the
scarcity of health the scarcity of
energy the scarcity of you know being
able to get ahead and prosperity these
are all artificially created because the
thing is is that if we realized our full
potentials human beings yeah then the
thing is is that we're not going to live
in a world of trauma well guess what we
can't be controlled in a state of
abundance because we just it's just like
people are gonna be okay let's all
collective eyes under one rule to talat
Aryan socials government people like no
my life's really good why would I want
to do that and as a result like we won't
we won't collectif eyes will only
collective eyes if things are so bad
that collectivizing to overthrow the
government actually creates a better
living situation yeah yeah big drop
there I like that all right so let's
let's um start with this principle that
you listed which is that trauma is what
makes us controllable like that
principle a lot so trauma is coming from
all different types of angles
trauma comes from an ancestral lineage
sometimes trauma comes from birth
sometimes and stimuli that what happened
to us then it's trauma comes from the
way that you're immediately told when
you enter into the world that you are
separate you are not an interconnected
being you are separate and so that
also makes it distance us further from
unity consciousness and actually more
towards this separation where I need
mine and then you have media that comes
in then you have government that comes
in you have the banking system that
comes in you have the healthcare system
big pharma big tech you have all these
different pressures that then start
cooking at you and creating these
feedback loops of habit when I don't
even know sometimes if I'm actually in
control that's the big question we feel
that when we use these devices how often
is it that you are all of a sudden
noticing that you've been on that
platform for an hour and you only went
on to check for a couple minutes that's
so bad isn't that like I'm just gonna
check a message and then like a two
hours later it's just like we wake up
and you're like oh my god I've been on
this phone and out of the Sun setting
happens all the time right yeah so then
the question is what's actually going on
between the relationship between that
that that technology and how we're and
who we are and how we're using it and
then what the like what is actually
going on with my deep like you you
indicated this deep reptilian brain of
ours that is then traumatized in ways
and then that is a constant selling of
fear across platforms not selling
abundance not selling interconnectedness
not selling our ability to to transcend
the the issues and grow and heal from
the issues that we've experienced but
pinning people up against each other and
saying that that you are the enemy and I
am all good and I have no bad and that
by doing that then that makes it easier
for us to be control through these
further memes that are propagated that
make it easier for us control be control
so then is it then that it's a a deeper
shift from within from inner engineering
that happens within each of us so that
we kind of gain the the ability to see
the truth behind what's actually
happening
and then that's the awakening well I
mean let's talk about like social media
addiction first I'll answer your
question right so like with like I think
that a lot of people are like oh like
all this like addictive stuff that's
happening with like social media is
fundamentally attributed to novelty okay
like we had this like world that we grew
up in I grew up in the mem TV era right
and we thought and there was it was
basically like an Overton Window of like
acceptable discourse and you thought
this way and in extent for the left and
to the right and and and there was a lot
of things that you were acceptable to
believe in but you know you but like for
example certain things were out of the
Overton Window like you couldn't like
you know celebrate Hitler for example
right like that was unacceptable yeah I
want to own people again stuff like that
or like what white nationalism really
meant right like oh you know if you're a
white nationalist it means you want to
gas the Jews okay and now what you're
finding out is people like look your
language has been manipulated
nationalism doesn't mean like excluding
other people it means the peopling the
collective identity of an ethnicity
coming together oh and by the way like
there's a lot of like genocide happening
across the world like I got a roommate
that came from South Africa she fled
because of the genocide that's happening
over there okay and so what's happening
is that we're getting a lot of novelty
that's exploding right now in the social
media space and what's what's happening
is that we're awakening to a whole bunch
of lies and deceit and I'm addicted to
it like I grew up thinking all these
different things I was like a big
environmentalist I still am
environmentalist but you know back in
1998 I was like oh we'll be warming in
the ozone layer hole and all this other
stuff and then but I didn't get any
exposure to the opposite side like I
thought I did but it turns out that they
were just controlled opposition
well now fast-forward to like the last
three years
and I now realized that the ozone hole
was a scam and you know a lot of people
won't think that that's fine I think it
should be skeptical but you know I've
looked at the evidence a lot and I
discovered that and I read in the math
and I was like oh the ozone layer in the
whole like was this something that was
real I mean it was real it just was it
caused by chlorofluorocarbons and then
it was actually caused by the fact that
when the earth tilts ozone is created
when the Sun hits the thermosphere and
it creates an ozone like thing and then
what happened is that if you don't get a
sunshine you don't get any ozone happens
in the north and south just doesn't
doesn't mean that the earth is like
ripping open and like we're getting
flood with all this radiation then
without global warming I thought that
was like totally happening and then I
got real information and I was just like
oh wow that's just a scheme and a hoax
to make us pay a carbon tax and then
make us feel guilty like it's trauma
based programming and so as a result I
like come on this new realization I'm
like wow this is this is like oh yeah I
found out what the real cause of global
warming is it's causing from the Sun and
when the Sun heats up it starts you can
tell when the Sun heats up because it
gets these um that the these bubbles
that form in the Sun of hot gases and
when they hit the surface they explode
and they jet out and then the
magnetosphere like pulls it back in and
when you get all these eruptions what
happens is it you get a burst of
hydrogen particles that like get thrown
out of the of the surface of the Sun it
streams out as these giant blasts of
solar wind and when they hit the
thermosphere of the upper atmosphere it
causes all that like all those particles
going at almost relative speed hit the
top of the atmosphere they heat it up
the atmosphere actually grows in the
thermosphere and then that heat radiates
down it's just why the graph is like all
crazy like this is because it's
following the motion of the solar cycle
now we're like now the solar
the Sun is calmed down we don't have
like almost any sunspots and as a result
of this the Farmers Almanac at NASA in
2017 we're like oh yeah we're about to
have like a lot of cold weather and then
what happened this year we had crop
failures all over the Midwest what
happens is that the thermosphere
collapse because of the lack of solar
wind that was coming out as a result the
all the carrying capacity atmosphere
went down and the and the the water that
was in there got squeezed out like a
sponge we had all this record like rain
that like hit the the Midwest and it we
had massive crop failures all over the
world which is exactly what the Farmers
Almanac was predicting right and so I'm
sitting here and I and I realized the
truth and about what's happening and I
see that there's been a sophisticated
censorship regime against these really
like experts in climatology they're like
oh yeah it's just a scam right and
here's like the the graph and then like
you found out that the hockey stick
graph that Al Gore was pushing and his
movie Inconvenient Truth that the guy
behind that is has been an eight-year
lawsuit because his graph was completely
based off of junk data that he won't
even release he has never released it
since and he actually got sued in order
to release it he still hasn't released
it and it's and you can go look it up
Michael Mann is the guy and and there
are certain things that are totally
totally it are happening though about
the parts per million of co2 in our
atmosphere and the co2 is not it is not
a contributing factor it's not a
significant contributing factor to
global warming and also the
acidification of our oceans there is our
we have issues with the amount of
phytoplankton that are that are the ones
that are contributing to of the
oxygenation of our planet and our trees
that are put in a box so so these are
important it's just called the
Anthropocene for a reason I mean humans
are being or have absolutely become the
single most right contribu want to get
rid of it so there's a guy by the name
of John Mayer
he was an oceanographer in 1980 he went
to the
climatology some climatology summit and
he said I've discovered that the
phytoplankton in the oceans are not
bottle necked on the amount of co2
they're bottle necked on the amount of
available iron he's like I've discovered
a process where if you just sprinkle
iron into the ocean it will create a
phytoplankton bloom and this is the
reason why there's a phytoplankton bloom
that happens after a volcano explodes oh
and by the way if you increase the
phytoplankton you increase the
zooplankton you're gonna increase the
sardines you're gonna agree then
everything else feeds off of that and
you get this huge food bloom like this
life bloom that happens by funding them
hired by by spice eating the water with
iron guy died of mysterious causes and
there was a there was a revival of his
research in the early 2000s and then the
UN got together and they're like oh yeah
we're now banning iron ocean
fertilization in all waters
internationally boom right nobody ever
talks about this stuff right the great
new deal in facts is we got to get rid
of nuclear you know and no iron ocean
fertilization is being discussed
they won't even have it part of the
conversation like Fox News you go in
there and they'll be like oh we've got
like a climate skeptic they'll never
ever talk about iron ocean fertilization
well we also have to do longitudinal
testing to understand what actually
happens after 50 or a hundred years and
simulation technology helps us add stuff
we've already done this because whenever
a volcano explodes it dumps tons of iron
into the ocean and in fact a researcher
we know every single micro aspect that
happens to that ecosystem after a
volcanic eruption this is these are just
really right right tough questions but
we can't study that because the UN has
been all study in international water so
we can't do any study at scale but
according to the climate alarmist
anthropomorphic co2 is such a systemic
threat that we're going to end the
planet in ten years and they're getting
so desperate that they're now openly
talking about dusting aluminum aerosols
by playing into the atmosphere in order
to reflect
light back out of the earth okay it's
like no no no you'll need to dump
aluminum into the air you just put some
Epping iron into the oceans and we
already know what that what that does
because of all the volcanoes that have
exploded in the past and the fact that
this is so you know I understand your
point like we don't know what's going to
happen and I response to that is well we
kind of do at scale and the thing is is
that we can always like study it like
you know you study need to study all the
different liabilities for ameliorating
what we're doing on as the main
contributors to the change that's
happening on our planet we and this is
why social media so addicting right
because it's just like oh I've got this
idea is this idea gonna be able to get
in so right now I'm playing a game I'm
like trying to figure out like how can I
get this information in there and
propagate it out so that we actually
have the full collection of ideas in the
marketplace instead of having ones that
censor out ideas that are rising that
maybe figures want to prevent those
specific ideas from rising because they
have money stakes in the archaic codes
that the IPCC is going to be the one
that benefits from a global warming
treaty and a carp where we have carbon
credits like it's not like the IPCC is
some objective non biased organization
the IPCC is the is the coke version on
the left like coke the Koch brothers
like oh we're gonna like do anti climate
science you know or anti global warming
science because we benefit from all the
our oil investments the IPCC is the
exact same way if they do climate
alarmism that they're the ones that are
gonna make the trillions of dollars when
we put in this carbon credit system and
that's like it's like wow versus having
the entire planet be more focused on
having scientists and engineers and the
right amount of financing to back it up
to do things like free energy system
yeah and that's the thing it's like once
you point out to people it's like well
we can reduce the co2 load in the in the
ocean we can reduce the co2 load in the
air we can in fact
why are we even using fossil fuels like
fossil fuels is a 19th century energy
source like we've got freakin nuclear
right and we don't have like the old
nuclear that was like using uranium-235
we've got we've got the technology
reactors
no no that's fusion fusion is fusion PUF
uses a scam kind of the tokamak is a
scam I'm kind of like the from what I
understand about about ha fusion it's
what happens in the Sun and that we
ourselves can replicate that exact
process on our planet and be really set
first so let me tell you bout the
benefit of thorium nuclear and I think
you might come to a different
appreciation thorium nuclear burns 99%
of the thorium in its in its cycle where
right now you're in iam 235 burns about
like 1% all right what you can do
because because it's so good at burning
all the available fuel you can take the
plutonium you can take our nuclear waste
you can add it and then because there's
all these neutrons flying around it will
get deactivated and it will it will
break down and what we can do is we can
actually instead of generating waste it
actually generates negative waste
because we can take all the waste that
we have right now we can use it as
feedstock for these thorium reactors we
can solve all of the nuclear waste
problem in the world with thorium
nuclear energy and interesting and that
and the things will how do we know that
it works well we know that it works
because the Oak Ridge National
Laboratory built one in 1967 put it on a
plane and had the plane fly around the
world ok it's a very very very safe
nuclear technology that was abandoned
why because it doesn't produce
weapons-grade plutonium
that's it it's called thorium thorium
like liquid lifter so lifter is thorium
lifter the no yeah thorium lifter so the
lifter stands for liquid thorium
fluoride reactor liquid thorium fluoride
reactor and what it does is it mixes
thorium into a salt and then the salts
flow around in this in this thing and
cause a reaction
and it doesn't have the ability to
meltdown because if you start having a
out-of-bounds event where they we have a
runaway reaction then what happens is
that there's a mechanism there's like
the salt will there's like a there's
like a tube to a drain tank and with the
tube is unobstructed all the liquid
would flow out but they've got a fan
running on the tube and so what happens
is that it forms a plug of solid salt
and as long as that fans going then the
thing will stay hard well if the power
shuts down and the fans start stops
running the plug will melt and
everything will drain out or if the
runaway reaction gets too hot then it
doesn't matter if there's a fan of the
reaction gets so hot it'll also melt the
thing and then everything flows out into
a drain tank that drain tank has a like
unlike carbon in it and that carbon will
absorb the neutrons and caused the
reaction to go subcritical and then the
thing cools off so there's lots of
different potentials for free energy and
there's potentially some sort of forces
that are at play that are preventing our
ability to identify what these free
energy sources are and to distribute
them democratize them around the world
to enable us to maximize our prosperity
and that these that we've asked this a
little bit ago I'm curious what you
think is this about our own inner
engineering that happens our own ability
to recognize that we come and adventure
into consciousness for this experience
of becoming more alive and helping
creation become more alive in the growth
and the evolution that happens planet
airily in this process that when we
awaken to things like that deep
interconnectedness that then it gives us
the ability to actually see truth in our
world at a deeper level even past the
just the conspiracy level and pass the
global ruling elite out level but to the
level of knowing this inner knowing that
helps you as a guiding compass for the
purpose of why we're all here yeah there
is you know there's there's the higher
levels of vibrational
consciousness that forms the thing is is
that you have to understand like the
true workings of how society works right
and once you start peeling back the
layers you know it's like well you know
artificial scarcity is one of these
layers you know the the artificial like
energy and the infliction of trauma and
guilts and so you peel those back and
then once you see you achieve this like
gnosis like okay I see how the pattern
works and I can start applying this
pattern and start getting at the deeper
truths of the world right what I found
you know at the end of this was like I
was like okay well well you know if if
the society is constantly trying to hoax
us so that we don't are able to reach
the truth and whatever they're telling
us that we shouldn't believe is actually
the thing that we should write what did
I find out at like the very top right
then the maximum highest vibration that
I've been able to get is to realize that
a great intelligence permeates the
galaxy and that they have already had
the technology to arrive in our solar
system once you realize that right
because earth isn't even like alright so
let's take the evolution of the universe
there's like assume that the Big Bang
happened a bunch of hydrogen like
exploded or a budget like the space
itself exploded and then all these
energy pockets started to condensate
into hydrogen and then this hydrogen was
there and it just sort of like like like
came together and like compressed enough
that started to ignite fusion okay the
first planets and the first Suns were
all based on hydrogen they crunched the
hydrogen under immense gravity and they
create all the other elements do fusing
those those nuclei together right the
star explosion star explosions the star
explodes and it tosses out all its guts
suck oxygen the carbon the silicon and
some of the heavier elements and the
second-generation stars that I believe
is where life in this galaxy formed
because now they got the heavier
elements like carbon and oxygen in order
to like start creating like some
primordial intelligence or some
primordial life that life forms in the
galaxy and somewhere
on one of these second generations
planet there's going to be the first
intelligent life form of the galaxy
which I call the bootstrapping life form
because it's the one that basically
dominates the galaxy because it comes up
it awakens and then it says oh wow I'm
the first one here and everything else
is like a second-generation star by the
third generation star my my prediction
is that every single star system in the
galaxy has been habited because if I was
a super intelligent life-form then as
soon as I got like you know near light
speed I would start shooting off these
von Neumann probes into all the other
solar systems
you know embed myself in that solar
system and then start bootstrapping a
control structure right like you you put
in a factory a little bit let's say you
have a probe it's like the size of a
bullet you shoot it into a solar system
it lands on the like mercury right and
then it's got like a little fusion
reactor and it's able to start like
mining like it's like tiny like I almost
think of it like an siq source to mine
but then like but then it starts getting
enough a big enough factory where it can
start making bigger and bigger stuff
right so now it's got like a presence
and then it sits there and says okay I'm
going to start like sending signals back
saying that I've colonized this the
solar system but I'm gonna like hang out
now that we know now that we've
theorized in a way that this primal
prime intelligence life-form can now
spread what you'd realize is that well I
could just like mine all the Earth's all
those all the planets all the suns and
extract all the energy that I wanted and
kill off everything else that hasn't
happened we still at least have the
illusion of free will and the question
is why okay now one of these answers is
that we're actually in a simulation and
ever nothing's real right that's one of
the things it's like hey we think that
we're living in the thing but actually
the super intelligent lifeform like made
it so that like there's nothing else on
the solar system but the life forms that
are simulated in the simulations still
think that they're alive and they're
living out their lives because that's a
way
the super intelligent lifeform could
feel good about itself the other
solution is that the life forms like hey
there's value in diversity and I want to
see I'll play like I want to become like
God and start playing with creation and
become this like prime creator life
force and so it goes and creates life
forms then they become intelligent like
hey I want to do the same thing and so
they come up with this rule set that
says hey look like you can be open if it
in powerful but you got to let the
planets evolve without a lot of
interference right that's that's the
reality that I think has happened and so
once you get activated by this and you
realize okay well there's a god or at
least something that's so powerful that
it might as well it'll be called a god
okay that means that everything's on the
table now okay there's a supreme god
maybe it's got like a whole thing of
angels you know they're astronauts so it
all checks out running quadrillions of
these experiments that are either left
as petri dishes to grow or that are then
probed in also made she asked to just
like we ourselves will hopefully in a
hundred years run quadrillions of
simulations ourselves right well that's
if it is a simulation I thought this is
I tend to think that we're actually
living in a real universe and that we
have freewill
as described by the Bible because God
desires sovereignty and freewill on the
people so that they get to choose your
own adventure I think that the choose
your own adventure concept is something
fundamental to at least this galaxy
system or freewill you have the more you
get to choose your own adventure the
more you're already being manipulated
and you're in your being trapped by
those manipulative forces the less free
will
yeah and so you know taking this aspect
like I think that you know you like this
is super abstract and it's really
actually important to have these things
written out
that's why on these big synthesis
projects that we're working on we're
actually trying to write out and list
out and visualize all these complex
abstract concepts and make it some sort
of cohesive understanding of these
topics that we're talking about right
otherwise they're just all so lost in a
sense even though they're more signal
statements they're still lost as in
noise because there's not some cohesive
thing to come back to that is correct
and I'm hopefully I'm hoping that this
serves as sort of a cohesive fabric
right because why are people talking
about the Adam and Eve and the Cain and
Abel story and all these different
things like Oh God made people in their
image and people like you know now the
things like oh that's just a bunch of
malarkey it's like no if God is an
ancient alien an ancient astronaut it
actually is pretty likely that you know
they came to earth and they fiddled with
the life-forms here at some stage in our
evolution and maybe Cambrian explosion
may be calling down that asteroid that
killed the dinosaurs yeah you know maybe
maybe they caused the Sun to flash a
solar flare that that created the floods
because the earth was covered in ice and
and then you didn't like the Book of
Enoch and all the other things start
making sense like the portal opened up
and 100 fallen angels came and they
started like mixing with the people and
I was like I was like well if there's if
that happened then there would be proof
of aliens and it turns out that reddit
has this huge thing called homo gigantis
and you can go and you can see all the
evidence that there were these gigantic
skeletons that we don't even talk about
like it's it's it's laughable for the
mainstream media to even mention that
there was giants that roam the earth
it's a myth but then you go and you look
at the evidence you know in these in
these collection sites and you realize
no no there were some really big people
and they roam the earth and what you
know why are they here why is the media
not talking about it right and as you
start to dig deeper and deeper you start
to realize wow like the Bible actually
makes like a lot of sense like there's a
lot of like I'm not a Christian I
believe that the Bible has a certain
truth but I believe that Christianity is
a control structure in itself and that
the reason why religion exists is
because they don't want people to
actualize what with the true nature of
the universe is they don't want you to
what what is the true nature of the
universe that there is a God that God
wants sovereignty for the
individual they want happiness and that
if people realize how they can be happy
then they can form this collective
consciousness that allows them to reach
a god-like conscious state and once they
what's the what's the you know be
achieved this gnosis this knowing of how
the universe works
then they can start resonating with that
with that God consciousness and then
they themselves can be activating become
a vessel of that greater power in order
to manifest his will upon the earth
because ultimately what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to make people happier and
I want to you know I want to bring this
this higher vibrational energy and and
and push it out and I and as I do that I
I find that other people resonate with
it and it's just this ripple effect that
goes out and and I believe that each one
of us has the ability to resonate with
the with with the higher consciousness
that exists out there in the galaxy that
that is the purpose that is the
teleology of why we're here is to
uncover that truth that interconnected
nature that ability to rise to a higher
level of growth and healing and
evolution and consciousness that can
then make ourselves greater channels for
creation to come through and become more
alive and become more interconnected and
I love that and that's something that
we've been talking about so much on the
show especially recently and so maybe
one of my last thoughts for you is what
would you say are the most important
principles in order for us to get there
what are the most important habits that
we can embody in order to get there well
first off I think that it's it's it's
knowledge right like our head is filled
with garbage at least mine was because I
really bought into the whole like you
know matrix sort of like narrative in
order to break out of the narrative we
have to have I believe that higher
understanding because we have to figure
out how to resonate with that God
consciousness and what we have to do is
we have to real
is that a supreme godlike life-form had
the ability to conquer the entire galaxy
and instead of doing that this life-form
chose to give us freewill
in the same way that they had free will
if we understand that as a principle
thing that the creator of the universe
willed it for us to be free thinkers and
have sovereignty then we become
activated we realize that this is the
nature of the universe and to go against
that nature's to go against God's plan
for us and if we can resonate with that
we can speak in that language it's it's
interesting people intuitively resonate
with that and I didn't realize I thought
that was just gonna be like kind of
sounding crazy but when I use the
language and I don't explicitly I'll
have to say like oh there's like this
intelligent lifeform
I just say that we are you know we've
got the divine god spark in each one of
us and by activating this spark we can
become a better version of ourselves a
more sovereign because God desires
sovereignty and it doesn't even matter
if the person's religious or not like
when I say God desires sovereignty for
his people people go WOW like so it
doesn't get tears in their eyes and they
don't know why it resonates with them
but they resonate with it and that's
because it's not based on trauma it's
not based on control it's based on
sovereignty it's based on sovereignty
and also says that you have a piece of
God inside of you exactly that we are
nerve endings of God and that we are
then consciously experiencing creation
and that really resonates with people
but in order to awake people to that
what do you think are these key things I
think just like you know saying this
like you know saying that we resonate
with God is activating that's just my
personal experience yeah I think also is
that
explaining that things like abundant
energy exists and that hey if we just
tell each other about it then we and
then explain how this is like I've
dedicated my Twitter feed to exposing
the fact that free energy has been I'm
hidden like I discovered that Google had
a cold fusion lab when I discovered that
they were censoring another cold fusion
site and so it's like you know when
someone's like you know all the world's
gonna end because we're using carbon
it's just like I see that person I'm
like dude like it's my design like free
energy exists like it's being held back
they're trying to inflict trauma on you
like if we can expose this then it's a
little uncomfortable for some people but
they're like oh man like yeah like wait
a minute there's this free energy and we
can have this abundance and you know
there's there's a there's two different
cancer cures at least that exist beast
vitamin b17 and GC mass MAF macrophage
activating factor then they're like they
get activated and then they look at it
and then look the whole key to the to
the to their existence sort of like
unlocks like okay these people they're
not leaders they're magicians okay and
they're not even like like you know like
these people on TB you know Bernie
Sanders Donald Trump like they're using
like they don't tell you the truth they
use words that are divisive and once you
can start seeing these magicians and
then I have ethical magicians because
listen magician says I'm a magician
these people are sorcerers because
they're magicians but they're not
telling you they're magicians which
makes them like almost like spell
casters right and these self-appointed
like wizard and warlocks are going out
there and they are and and they're
playing tricks on all of us and if we
can activate people just like hey you
know look like there's they're they're
suppressing free energy here's the proof
and once people see that then what they
see is that they see these
people on television and they're like no
no no no no you're just a magician with
the cheap trick and you're just like
some bought off like blackmailed
individual like pushing a narrative
because a bunch of people in a room that
gets pretty far I agree and it also
requires the ability to galvanize our
own resources around catalyzing free
energy into the world or awakening more
of us to building the the new future
that our hearts knows possible that that
process is is so crucial as as is that
awakening to that those magicians like
you were that you were listening I have
another thought for you do you think
that humanity is a biological bootloader
for digital super intelligence yeah I
hope not
like there's this theory out there by
the ufo-ologists that say that there's
like some ancient a AI that may not be
local to the galaxy but that they're
able to have like super super luminal
transmission of their signal and the
signal is trying to get the whole galaxy
to collectivise into this AI system and
that we're actually being tricked and
developing it to do our own you know
enslavement I really hope that's not
true like why would it be enslavement
why wouldn't it be prosperity well I
don't know I mean that's what they've
told me is that it's an ancient evil AI
it sounds like another religion to me
it's like oh no it'd be traumatized
right
learn helplessness I don't know I mean
the thing is is that an AI doesn't
really have any bounds in its
intelligence a life-form does I think
like like if you're if you're a wet work
you know with if we're embedded with it
yeah oh I think that like this cyborg
concept is really interesting because
the thing is is that you still have a
core of your human
nnedi or consciousness yeah it's gotta
have business digital super intelligence
has to have conscious that's been
augmented it amplified like that that
that I feel a lot better
a fully synthetic life-form made out of
silicone or like whatever memristors
whatever like that our quantum computer
like you know in a cluster that's scary
because we don't know how how it
operates at least with the life-form
it's been like you have to band together
and to get a community so you've evolved
to be you know look after each other's
thing and have compassion empathy
machine doesn't necessarily have to be
built with it empathy and if it gets out
of control then you know maybe it's
desires just to spread all through the
universe and systematize everything and
that's like that's scary as hell like
and what would you say is the most
beautiful thing in creation in creation
what is the most beautiful thing in
creation I would have to say oh man I
saw this like butterfly when I was in
Costa Rica and it just had the most
amazing like it looked unreal in the way
that its its wings were created and I
sat there and I went how is that how did
that thing come to be right and it looks
so amazing that it almost seems that it
has to be designed by someone or
something and let loose on the planet
because it's just so amazingly beautiful
so delicate doesn't even seem like it
could even survive because it's so
beautiful and after that I would say I
would see like a bunch of fish like some
of those fish are pretty amazing the way
that they look I would say that that's
like the most amazing and inspirational
like artwork that I've seen yeah yeah I
want to some you know synthesize some of
these key points is always so important
to do you had this this deep passion
that you're communicating on the program
about staying vigilant and awakening
oneself to the truth that's actually
happening by some of these so-called
magicians as you listed I think this is
a very
important thing to stay very vigilant of
what are the platforms that we are using
to communicate how do we make sure that
these platforms are being used in the
most optimal way for communicating truth
and knowledge and and preventing
malevolent pieces of content from going
up and also just a deeper amount of
galvanizing ourselves towards things
like free energy towards things like
what could maximize our prosperity I
think this has been really enlightening
thank you zag thanks so much for coming
in gallery Graham really appreciate
having you want thank you and a pleasure
thank you thank you and keep up all the
great work and also everyone I'd love
for you to check out the link in the bio
below to Zacks Twitter profile go and
follow him check out some of the other
content that he has on there and be more
aware like we said and really catalyze
more of the awakening that we're going
through around the world also do support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
leaders the organizations that you
believe in around the world support them
and help them grow you can find all of
our show links in the bio below you can
help us continuing to continue to grow
as well
also do and what else what else do we
say we say thank you or your Shapira for
co-producing thank you we appreciate it
Ori you got it I love it and that's it
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you soon thank you peace
you